(jolly ringtone)
(electricity crackling)
- Yo man, it's Gary Vee.
I wish I prioritized my health.
I could have slept one hour less,
I could have worked,
and this is a crazy one,
I could have worked one less hour,
I could have done a whole lot of things,
but I should have found that one hour
to do what I've been doing
for the last 65 days,
and prioritize my health.
(electricity crackling)
You know, I knew that what
I was doing in business,
what I was doing in friendship,
what I was doing in parenting,
that was all on point,
but in the back of my mind
I knew that my health wasn't there, right?
But the way I was rolling, I should have
looked a thousand times worse
than I looked back then.
My weight and just my body
structure, my natural DNA,
kept it in check enough
that I wasn't 400 pounds,
because there was no good eating habits,
basically there was zero exercise,
zero to the time I was 38
and a half, when I did this.
So it's on the back of my
mind since I turned 30,
"Crush It!" came out in 2009, I was 34,
it's been there, it's been there.
And then I'm on a flight, I'm
just sitting in the plane,
head against the window,
again it pops in my mind,
randomly I'm like "I really
need to get my shit together."
At 30 is when I said "I've
gotta change my business.
I'm doing it well, but if I
really wanna buy the Jets,
or really accomplish crazy things,
I have to make a huge turn."
And on my thirtieth birthday,
I made that turn mentally.
Literally my thirtieth birthday,
I was driving to the
store, I looked myself
in the rear-view mirror, and
I said "you're full of shit.
Your mouth is ahead of your actions.
You ain't buying the Jets,
you're not gonna buy a jet,
you can't buy a jet airplane.
Get your shit together."
And that's literally when I decided
to start Wine Library TV and
go into the Web 2.0 thing.
Hello everyone, and welcome to
the first episode of Wine Library TV.
Today, we're going to explore
the Wine Library wine room.
Temperature controlled, lots
of buzz, 3000 square feet.
And it's changed my life, right?
And so I said "you know what?
I'm gonna do the health version of that
on my fortieth birthday."
And before I even landed, so
somewhere within three hours,
the conversation with myself went from
"the hell am I gonna wait 'til 40 for?
I'm gonna do this at 39."
And then I said "wait a minute.
why am I gonna wait 'til November?"
This was like March, right?
I go "let's do it now."
You've gotta make the mental switch,
in the same way that two years ago
I said I gonna make the,
there way no tactic.
Just making that switch of
going all-in, not doing tactics.
When you ask D Rock,
has he been working out?
- Yeah.
- I said no, because you're not,
unless you completely go black and white.
You agree with me that it is
a mental switch, not a tactic.
There's no like "you're
gonna do this", it's binary.
Either you're mentally in the place of
"I take this seriously", or you're not.
- 'Cause life does whatever it's gonna do,
you just decide what
you're gonna do around it.
And that happens with
exercise too, I think so.
Yeah just go with it, or you don't.
- One to zero.
- I figured out my
health by tricking myself
into a system where I was
accountable to somebody else.
I genuinely believe this is a binary game.
Either you keep yourself accountable,
or you're gonna be
accountable to somebody else.
I think a lot of people
that struggle with fitness,
and health and fitness,
and really probably
in life in general, in
different disciplines,
is they're unable to be
accountable to themselves.
I figured out that I needed
a full-time health person
that was not my full-time trainer,
that was my full-time health person.
Meaning they only worked for
me, period, end of story.
That I would make that
big financial commitment,
and that I would be
accountable to that person.
So I call Mike, I said
"do you know somebody?"
And he said "well I would do it."
And I go "whoa, you're gonna
give up all your other stuff?"
He's like "yeah, it's worth it."
- There's something he doesn't know,
that I'm about to tell him,
because it's our last workout ever,
is that I'm working out with you today.
- What do you mean it's
our last workout ever?
- Jordan tomorrow.
- And that's it?
- And that's it!
(laughing)
- I didn't even know that!
- Yeah!
- I just got sad.
- Yeah, I've been sad.
- I'm now two and a half, three years in,
Mike did it for two years,
now I'm with Jordan,
he'll do it for three
years, he's six months in.
(electricity crackling)
- [Cameraman] So when you
have taken over with Gary,
what has been your main focus?
- We've actually gone through a bunch
of different focuses throughout.
The main thing, number one,
was helping him feel really good.
That was from day one to
now, the most important thing
is make sure he feels
really good, no pain.
So we've improved his soft
tissue quality all over,
especially in his hips and his legs.
And then now, also in addition to that,
we just wanna stack on some muscle,
for the next couple of months,
before we start doing a
little bit of a summer cut.
(electricity crackling)
- It's been game-changing.
I'm much more athletic and nimble,
I've been really chopping
away at my inefficiencies.
I workout seven days a week, seven.
I'm in the gym every, and
one day maybe a stretch,
or things of that shape, but nonetheless
it does not come natural to me.
This did not come natural to me.
There's fat Gary keynotes,
cut it in right now Tyler or D Rock.
There's a right way to get
a six-pack for your stomach.
There's exercises, and there's a diet.
I know what they are, I'm not doing it.
You know, I tell a lot
of my creative friends,
I'm like "you need to
find a business partner.
Give somebody 10, there's so many people
out there marketing shit,
go find one of those people
and let them market your great
stuff, and give up 10 to 50%
if it takes that much,
because at the end of the day,
if you're trying to make it
a living, it's a business.
And if you don't know
how to run a business,
or if you don't know what to do,
oftentimes it doesn't work out.
(electricity crackling)
But most of all, I feel
good about the long-term.
I know when I'm 50, 60, 70, 80, 90,
I'm gonna be in a better position,
than if I had not done this.
I'm gonna lose 15 pounds,
but all the muscle's
gonna be there, D Rock.
And that means shirtless keynotes.
(laughing)
(upbeat hip-hop music)
Of course it's supposed to be hard.
People are like "Gary, it's so hard."
No shit, asshole.
Are you willing to pay the
price for what you want?
You want a one percent life,
but you're not willing to put
in a one percent work ethic.
It's the stupidest thing of all time.
Why should that be easy?
Makes no sense.
Building something real takes time.
Everybody's impatient.
It's not just a young kid thing,
the world's impatient.
When I'm on the field, I'm all-in one way.
You can't be 50/50 working out,
50/50 in your relationships,
50/50 in your escapism,
50/50 in the way you play,
that's why everybody's average.
You have to be macro yin and yang,
micro all-in one way or the other.
If you can make that binary switch of
"I'm gonna work a lot, I'm not
gonna have excuses anymore.
I'm gonna be very patient, I'm gonna learn
how to build a business."
Then things can happen.
Just like I made a switch here,
forever, seven days a week, for life.
(electricity crackling)
Love you, talk soon, bye-bye.
(upbeat hip-hop music)